>> Jesse: YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO.
KEEP SOME EXTRA FOOD AND WATER
IN THE HOUSE IN CASE YOU GET
SNOWED IN.
HAVE A JEB RARITY JUST IN CASE A
STORM TAKES OUT YOUR POWER LINES
AND YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO
ESCAPE YOUR HOUSE IF THERE'S A
FIRE.
[SHOUTING]
[SCREAMING]
HELP.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT THE OFFICE
OF EVERY DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
AND STRATEGIST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY LOOKS LIKE RIGHT NOW.
D.C. INSIDER MARK HALL WHO IS
ONE OF THE MOST PLUGGED IN
PEOPLE IN POLITICS SAYS
DEMOCRATS HE IS SPEAKING TO ARE
IN A LIVING NIGHTMARE.
THEY FINALLY SEE THE MASSIVE
WAVE SURGING TOWARD THEM AND
THEY ADMIT THERE IS NOTHING THEY
CAN DO ABOUT IT.
DEMOCRATS SAY THEIR PRIVATE
POLLS ARE SHOWING WORSE NUMBERS
THAN THE PUBLIC POLLS.
AND THE PUBLIC POLLS ARE JUICED
LEFT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS BAD.
VOTERS ARE GIVING DEMOCRAT DOOR
KNOCKERS THE MIDDLE FINGER AS
SOON AS THEY STEP ON THE FRONT
PORCH.
BLACK PASTORS SAY THERE IS NO
ENTHUSIASM IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
VOTERS ARE CHANTING LET'S GO
BRANDON WHEN CANVASSERS KNOCK ON
THEIR DOORS AND EVEN NEVER TRUMP
SUBURBAN MOMS CANNOT WAIT FOR
VOTE FOR KARI LAKE AND TUDOR
DIXON IN MICHIGAN AND LEE ZELDIN
IN NEW YORK.
DEMOCRATS FRYING TO PLUG HOLES
IN BLUE STATES LIKE OREGON,
COLORADO, NEW YORK, AND
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY GOING ON
OFFENSE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS
DEMOCRATS HAVE COWERED INTO A
DEFENSIVE CROUCH, SO, HOW DID
THIS HAPPEN?
INFLATION, CRIME, AND JOE BIDEN.
WE'RE ON OUR HANDS AND KNEES BEG
BEGGING FOR LEADERSHIP, BEGGING
FOR ANSWERS.
JOE BIDEN ACTS LIKE HE CAN'T
HEAR US.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
[SHOUTING]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
[SHOUTING]
LET'S GO.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T CARE IF
PRICES ARE HIGH.
BESIDES MSNBC SAYS FIGHTING
INFLATION IS FOR NAZIS.
WHILE BIDEN SITS IN SILENCE, THE
SQUAD THOUGH FILLS THE VOID AND
THE COUNTRY HEARS.
THIS.
>> I WAS ON A FLIGHT ON THE WAY
OUT HERE AND THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANT JUST KIND OF CAME UP
TO ME AND SHE JUST STARTED
GETTING TEARS IN HER EYES AND
SHE JUST SAID I'M JUST SO
SCARED.
I'M JUST SO SCARED.
ARE WE GOING TO BE OKAY?
AND WHAT I HAD TO REALLY TELL
HER WAS, LISTEN, I'M NOT GOING
TO TELL YOU NOT TO WORRY.
I THINK WE NEED TO WORK REALLY,
REALLY HARD BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
VERY MUCH AT THIS VERY CRITICAL
PRECIPICE OF FASCISM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: MUST BE HARD BEING AOC
AND IF YOU ARE NOT GETTING HIT
ON YOU ARE GETTING CRIED ON.
THIS IS SO TYPICALLY OF
LIBERALS.
PEOPLE ARE BEING SHOT DEAD IN
THE STREET AND THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT AN ISM FROM 80 YEARS AGO.
FILLY LOOKS LIKE AFGHANISTAN.
LAST WEEK, FOUR SHOOTERS LIT UP
A BLOCK.
54 ROUNDS FIRED.
54.
ONE GUY GOT SHOT EIGHT TIMES.
IN OHIO POLICE WERE FORCED TO
GUN DOWN AN ARMED MAN RUNNING
TOWARD A HIGH SCHOOL, WATCH.
>> ALL THE SECOND DOG STELLA.
GET OUT OF THE CAR, DROP IT.
DROP THE GUN.
DROP IT.
I WILL SHOOT YOU.
[SHOUTING.
[.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE LUCKY.
THEY ARE ONLY GETTING THE MIDDLE
FINGER WHEN THEY KNOCK ON
VOTERS' DOORS.
LIKE USUAL, DEMOCRATS ONLY CARE
ABOUT CRIME IF IT HAPPENS TO
THEM PERSONALLY.
DEMOCRAT KATIE HOBBES FROM
ARIZONA SAYS THIS GUY BROKE INTO
HER CAMPAIGN HEADQUARTERS.
AND SHE SUGGESTING THAT HER
OPPONENT, KARI LAKE IS BEHIND
IT.
WELL, SHE HAS NO PROOF OF THAT.
BUT IT DEFINITELY MAKES A GOOD
HEADLINE BEFORE THE ELECTION.
RIGHT?
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE AFRAID
TO DEBATE AND YOU ARE DROPPING
LIKE A ROCK IN THE POLLS.
AND ISN'T IT INTERESTING THAT
HOBBES IS THE ONE WHO RELEASED
THE PHOTOS OF THE SUSPECT, NOT
THE POLICE SHE DOESN'T KNOW IF
THE GUY TOOK ANYTHING SHE SAYS.
NOT EXACTLY WATERGATE BUT THE
MEDIA IS EATING IT UP.
HOW MUCH ARE YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN CANVASSER WHO HAD HIS
JAW BROKEN FOR SUPPORTING MARCO
RUBIO.
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT HIM?
PROBABLY NOT UNLESS YOU WATCH
FOX.
OF THE GUYS WHO BEAT HIM UNJUST
GOT ARRESTED BY THE WAY.
DEMOCRAT STRATEGISTS ARE URGING
CANDIDATES TO TALK MORE ABOUT
CRIME BUT THE ONLY THING THEY
CAN MUSTER UP IS JANUARY 6TH.
DEMOCRATS CAN'T SHAKE THE STENCH
OF THE DEFUND THE POLICE.
MANDELA BARNES, THE DEMOCRAT
RUNNING AGAINST RON JOHNSON IN
WISCONSIN IS A BIG-TIME DEFUND
THE POLICE GUY.
IS HE ALSO THE SAME GUY WHO SAYS
LOVING GOD, COUNTRY AND GUNS IS
AS DANGEROUS AS ISIS.
OH, YEAH?
AND IN HIS FREE TIME.
BARNES BARNES LIKES TO CALL
WISCONSIN VOTERS RACIST.
>> THE RACISM THERE IS DIFFERENT
THAN HERE IN WISCONSIN BECAUSE
IN LOUISIANA AND MISSISSIPPI,
ALABAMA, IT'S MORE OPEN.
IT'S LIKE YOU GET IT.  YOU KNOW
THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T LIKE YOU
AND HERE IN WISCONSIN IT'S A
LITTLE MORE SCARY BECAUSE IT CAN
BE INSTITUTIONALIZED.
>> MUCH MORE HIDDEN.
>> MUCH MORE CONCEALED.
YOU KNOW WISCONSIN IS RACIST BUT
JEREMIAH WRIGHT IS ALL RIGHT.
>> NOT GOD BLESS AMERICA GOD
DAMN AMERICA THAT'S IN THE
BIBLE.
>> NOW WE ARE INDIGNANT BECAUSE
OF THE STUFF WE HAVE DONE
OVERSEAS IS NOW BROUGHT RIGHT
BACK INTO OUR OWN FRONT YARD:
AMERICA'S CHICKENS ARE COMING
HOME TO ROOST.
>> RAPHAEL WARNOCK FROM GEORGIA
IS EVEN MORE RADICAL THAN THAT.
>> AMERICA, NOBODY CAN SERVE GOD
AND THE MILITARY.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS NEXT
MONTH, MORE THAN A THIRD OF THE
NATION THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH
THIS IS REASON TO BE AFRAID:
AMERICA NEEDS TO REPENT FOR ITS
WORSHIP OF WHITENESS.
>> SO, IN FERGUSON, POLICE POWER
SHOWING UP IN A GANGSTER AND
THUG MENTAL TATTLE.
YOU KNOW, CAN YOU WEAR ALL KINDS
OF COLORS AND BE A THUG.
YOU CAN SOMETIMES WEAR THE
COLORS OF THE STATE AND BEHAVE
LIKE A THUG.
>> Jesse: SO DEMOCRATS ARE
WORRIED THAT THE RACE-BAITING
COP-HATING REVEREND MIGHT LOSE.
I WONDER WHY THAT THING DOESN'T
REALLY PLAY DOWN IN GEORGIA.
HUH.
I'M SURE FILLY VOTERS ARE GOING
TO LOVE THE WHITE GUY WHO CHASES
INNOCENT UNARMED BLACKS WITH
SHOTGUNS.
FETTERMAN STILL WILL NOT
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT ONE.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU APOLOGIZED TO
THAT UNARMED INNOCENT BLACK MAN
WHO YOU PUT A SHOTGUN TO HIS
CHEST?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I MADE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEFEND OUR COMMUNITY AS THE
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
THERE.
EVERYBODY IN BRADDOCK
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY COMMUNITY
OF BLACK COMMUNITY ALL
UNDERSTOOD WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW, THEY UNDERSTOOD WHAT
HAPPENED.
AND EVERYBODY AGREED THAT, AND
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT IT WAS
ANYTHING ABOUT ME MAKING A SPLIT
SECOND DECISION TO DEFEND OUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL.
>> Jesse: SO HIS WIFE, WILL
GIVE, YOU KNOW THE SHAH SHADOW
CANDIDATE WHOSE FAMILY IS TIED
TO FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE SAYS
THAT'S NOT RACIST.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE REAL RACISM.
WE DID NOT NOT THE MANSION THE
POOL.
THE POOL I WANTED'.
THE DREAM WAS TO OPEN THIS POOL
AND MAKE IT A PUBLIC POOL TURN
IT INTO THE PEOPLE'S POOL AND
INSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS
PENNSYLVANIA COULD LEARN HOW TO
SWIM AND LEARN WATER SAFETY AND
KIND OF WORK TO RIGHT SOME OF
THE WRONGS.
HISTORICALLY, SWIMMING IN
AMERICA IS VERY RACIST.
>> Jesse: BIDEN WAS A LIFEGUARD.
HE BEAT UP CORN POP AT THE POOL.
IS THAT RACIST?
PEOPLE OF BRADDOCK,
PENNSYLVANIA, THE TOWN WHERE
FETTERMAN WAS MAYOR AREN'T
REALLY THAT HAPPY WITH HIM.
HE DIDN'T MAKE THE TOWN ANY
BETTER.
BUT HIS CAMPAIGNING LIKE HE DID.
>> I'M ON MY WAY OUT HERE.
>> I KNOW, YOU AND EVERYBODY
ELSE.
WHEN FETTERMAN SAYS HEY, OH, I
HELPED CREATE JOBS IN BRADDOCK
WE ARE LIKE WHERE?
1700 OF US AND LIKE 5050 IN
BRADDOCK.
WE NEED A GROCERY STORE.
WE NEED BUSINESSES.
PEOPLE NEED JOBS.
>> Jesse: HE COULDN'T CUT AS IT
MAYOR AND HE IS DEFINITELY NOT
FIT TO SERVE AS SENATOR.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID YESTERDAY.
STAFF [INAUDIBLE]
>> AND HERE'S WHAT HE SAID
TODAY.
>> TALK ABOUT THE LIVER -- THE
LIBERTY OF STATE -- HAS NEVER
HAD AN INSCRIPTION INSIDE THAT
SAID, YOU KNOW, SEND YOUR TIRED
HUNTERRED MASSES.
>> AGAIN, WE ARE NOT HERE TO
MOCK FETTERMAN.
WE FEEL SORRY FOR HIM.
HE SHOULD BE RESTING AND
RECOVERING.
NOT RUNNING FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
EVERYBODY WHO SAW THE
OZ-FETTERMAN DEBATE TUESDAY
KNOWS FETTERMAN IS UNFIT FOR
OFFICE.
THEY KNOW THAT.
BUT SCHUMER THOUGHT THE DEBATE
WENT GREAT AND THEN GOT CAUGHT
ON A HOT MIC TODAY TELLING BIDEN
WHAT HE WANTS TO HEAR.
>> Jesse: IF BIDEN STARTED
LISTENING TO VOTERS INSTEAD OF
POLITICIANS, THIS COUNTRY WOULD
BE IN A LOT BETTER SHAPE.
HERE ARE THE PEOPLE OF
PENNSYLVANIA IN THEIR OWN WORDS.
>> FROM DAY BUN, ONCE HE HAD HIS
STROKE, I FELT HE SHOULD DROP
OUT.
I DON'T THINK HE IS HEALTHY
ENOUGH TO BE -- HOLD THE OFFICE.
>> IT ALMOST MADE HIM SEEM AS IF
HE WAS NOT EVEN QUALIFIED TO DO
THE FUNCTIONS OF THE OFFICE.
>> WE NEED SOMEBODY WHO IS GOING
TO BE A SOUND, HEALTHY MIN